for action movie buffs who thought that
the mind-bending sci-fi thrills of the
matrix trilogy were put to rest from the
third chapter of the franchise released
in 2003
think again the currently untitled
fourth installment of the futuristic
sci-fi franchise
is coming to blow audiences away once
again the slick and stylish action films
made big bugs at the box office with the
1999 original film grossing nearly 500
million dollars worldwide and broke the
mould when it came to using computerized
special effects
resulting in unique and groundbreaking
fight sequences
that still inspire action movies today
along with keanu reeves and kyrie and
moss also returning to the film will be
jada pinkett smith
and lambert wilson plenty of new faces
will join the cast as well
including christina ricci jonathan groff
jessica henwick and neil patrick harris
henwick is already very familiar with
shooting hard pulsing action scenes
and the physical demands that comes with
them she received extensive fight
training for her role in the marvel
netflix series iron fist where she
portrayed martial arts instructor
and all-around badass colleen wink
henwick also showed off her skills with
a bullwhip in game of thrones
playing one of the beautiful and deadly
sand snakes and daughter of oberyn
martel
nymeria sand fans might also recall her
role as x-wing fighter pilot
jess tester in star wars episode vii the
force awakens
although very little information is
known about her role in the new matrix
movie
henwick recently gave fans a little hint
about her preparations for the film
in an exclusive with empire i haven't
seen a cut of the film
so i don't know what's in it and what
isn't but i trained every day for months
there are a couple of cast members who
didn't have any physical stuff
and they were so sad how can you be in
the matrix and not get to do any of the
good stuff
as for what that good stuff involves
henwick went on to talk about her own
love for the original matrix films
henwick gushed i grew up thinking matrix
was the coolest thing ever
bullet time the multiple agents the
pills and the rabbit
she then offered a bit more of a tease
about her involvement stating
when i signed on i said the three things
i want are a leather jacket
sunglasses and some wire work i got two
out of the three
i'll leave you to guess which ones well
if we're playing the guessing game would
guess that the matrix 4 sounds like it's
going to have more awesome action
and mind-blowing fight sequences than
ever before
considering it's been nearly 20 years
since the original trilogy concluded
it would also be a safe bet that there
have been some big leaps in
technological advancements since then
with the potential for new and
groundbreaking special effects
to wow matrix audiences there was a time
when it seemed that the matrix franchise
had come to a conclusion
rumors that another potential matrix
film had been floating around for years
in spite of the fact that the wachowskis
have denied this claim several times
when asked about the prospect of making
another matrix movie in 2015
lilly wichowski considered the idea
particularly repelling
very strong words that appear to close
the book on the subject for good
however it seems that the siblings must
have had a change of heart at some point
because in 2019 variety announced that
lana wachowski would return to wright
and direct the fourth matrix film
reeves and master on board to reprise
their roles as neo and trinity the power
couple fighting for humanity's freedom
from enslavement by the machines warner
brothers and village roadshow pictures
are the distribution team behind the
matrix four
and lana wachowski has some help with
the script from co-writers david
mitchell
and alexander heman lana's sister lily
is noticeably absent from the production
as she is busy with her new showtime
series work in progress
in which she serves as a producer and
co-writer although she could not get
involved with the franchise that she and
her sibling began together
lily has said that she sincerely hopes
it's better than the original
the new movie is slated to release both
in theaters and on hbo max december 22nd
2021 check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about the matrix franchise are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one